wir versuchen die aktuelle lage
einzuordnen wie es weitergeht und was
passieren wird und zwar mit unseren
reportern die an allen aktuellen
brennpunkten stehen wir schon mal auf
die karte herbert bauernebel unser
washington korrespondent ist dort vor
ort und in der ukraine da wo es brennt
sind paul ronzheimer an der front mit
dem wir jetzt gleich sprechen werden
peter thiede ist auf russischer seite in
rostow am don peter hell ist in der
hauptstadt in kiew und philipp jakob ist
in lemberg in der west ukraine eine
wichtiger ort ein rückzugsort womöglich
auch werden die situation in kiew
dramatischer wird also beginnen wir
unseren überblick
direkt an der front und schalten zu paul
ronzheimer paul wo bist du jetzt gerade
thomas ich bin an einem front door vdfk
und bis gerade eben hat man hier
artilleriebeschuss gehört das ist ein
dorf ich zeige euch das mal über dieser
linie dort hinten sind die separatisten
und ob der seite weiter die ukrainische
armee also das geht hier quer sozusagen
durch den garten von ludmilla einer frau
die ich schon länger kenne wir haben
weiter von dort gerade
artilleriebeschuss gehört ich müsste
eigentlich schon längst wieder
schutzweste und helm tragen man hört es
auch im hintergrund gerade aber ich muss
sagen ich habe ein schlechtes gewissen
gegenüber den zivilisten hier mit einer
schutzweste aufzutreten denn die
flüchten wegen des atelier beschusses in
ihre keller und ich nehme euch hier
einmal mit um euch das zu zeigen wie das
aussieht in so einem keller blut millers
keller hier und sie hat sich in den
ganzen letzten tag und heute hierhin
zurück gezogen man sieht dass hier da
hat sie sich eine küche richtig
reingebaut ich zeig euch das mal nehmen
euch damit ihre katze ludmilla und ein
bisschen licht durch ein generator strom
wasser gibt es schon seit drei tagen
nicht mehr
erzählt dass ihre wände gewackelt haben
in den letzten tagen sie haben gewackelt
weil es so viel artilleriebeschuss gab
denn die stellung der ukrainischen armee
ist nur ungefähr 100 meter von hier
während aber sie hat keine schutzweste
sie hat keinen helm wie wir die ja
vermeintlich dann ein bisschen sicher
sind nein sie zieht sich hier zurück in
diesem keller ach diese tür zu und
versucht sich dann vor den truppen vor
und mörser sind natürlich nie ganz gut
da die verbindung ist leider sehr sehr
schlecht zu dir paul wir versuchen es
später noch mal ich bin jetzt wieder
jetzt geht es um durchschnitt wir da
heraus genau
ja das waren die bilder die wir gerade
gezeigt haben ich weiß nicht was ihr
verstehen konnten ludmilla die dorthin
geflüchtet ist gerade eben weil hier
artilleriebeschuss zu hören war in den
stellung auf dieser seite die quer durch
das dorf gehen sie hat keine helm sie
hat keine schutzweste sie kann sich
nicht schützen ja und deswegen versteckt
sie sich in diesem keller seit tagen
kein wasser mehr gestern hat hier das
haus gewackelt und sie geht davon aus
dass das hier jede minute auch wieder
passieren kann der präsident der ukraine
will npd hat eine teilmobilmachung von
reservisten jetzt angeordnet was
bedeutet das konkret
das bedeutet dass weitere
hunderttausende menschen möglicherweise
für die ukrainische armee kämpfen werden
dass sie aus aufgerufen werden zu
kämpfen insbesondere hier in dem gebiet
wo ich bin im don dass in dem gebiet um
die ostukraine um das ist momentan geht
denn man geht davon aus dass wladimir
putin mit den truppen die jetzt rein
kommen möglicherweise hier die teile die
noch von der ukraine gehalten werden
will angreifen will darunter große
städte nicht nur dörfer wo ich gerade
bin und das würde dann einen großen
blutigen krieg bedeuten ein krieg paul
in dem die ukraine auf sich alleine
gestellt sind das sind sehr
eindringliche bilder gewesen gerade die
uns zeigt dass von ludmilla dort in
diesem ärmlichen bunker während wir uns
hier sorgen darüber machen dass
vielleicht die benzinpreise steigen oder
die erdgaspreise natürlich auch
berechtigte sorgen aber nichts im
vergleich zu dem was du uns gerade
gezeigt hat ist menschen wie ludmilla
bewusst dass sie am ende auf sich allein
gestellt werden sein dass der westen
ihnen nicht zur hilfe kommen wird
ja den menschen ist bewusst dass
deutschland weggeschaut hat lange
nord stream nicht sanktionieren wollte
keinen druck auf putin gemacht hat ich
bin überrascht wie sehr deutschland hier
ein thema selbst eine ost ukraine
das ist tatsächlich etwas ja was die
menschen mitbekommen haben was die
unterstützung angeht wir haben viel über
die beiden rede gesprochen das ist etwas
was die menschen sagen da wird nichts
passieren da wird es keine unterstützung
geben und am ende steht die ukraine
alleine da gegen das was da jetzt in den
wahrscheinlich dunkelsten stunden
dunkelsten tagen seit sehr vielen
jahrzehnten in der ukraine auf dieses
land zukommt